[Music]
[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the nut King's message and
what it's supposed to mean as well as
about Danny tonight screen theory being
heavily hinted to come true by the first
episode of the final season at the end
of season 8 premiere we learned that
last card has fallen and the knight King
has left a message
tormund Giantsbane barrington Darian
Edison Tollett another survival saw the
world's destruction find the corpse of
little Lord umber strung up and
surrounded by several human limbs
arranged in a familiar spiral pattern
and are then forced to set it all aflame
when the boy comes back from the dead as
the white however this time perhaps
because now it's a fire it highly
resembles a Targaryen sigil and fans
have gone crazy about it on social media
everyone sees similarities here and many
claim that this confirms the netting is
a Targaryen theory this theory got even
more popularity after the premiere was
over the showrunner saying in their
review that only Targaryens have ever
ridden a dragon in the story since the
night king rides the dragon and his
symbol resembles Targaryen sigil a lot
fans are certain that the night king is
a Targaryen or at the very least his
message says he's after a Targaryen the
night king once a queen and then if
House Targaryen is the chosen one well
first of the night King is definitely
not off House Targaryen a Targaryen
cannot possibly be the night king
because they arrived investor of
thousands of years after the night king
was created the night king controls is
aryan through magic rather than through
the blood of the dragon which he doesn't
have the night king the oldest of the
White Walkers was a first man from the
children of the forest Scot and turned
into a white Walker to destroy the first
man Berg said it's a message from the
night king and since it looks like a
Targaryen schedule could I be the night
king saying he wants Dany Targaryen for
his queen is that why do i Walker star
even coming south one of my most popular
theories is that exact eerie and it's
Danny becoming the night screen the
night screen is an unseen woman in Game
of Thrones a legendary figure known in
the Seven Kingdoms and among the free
folk according to a legend the Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch found in a
haunted forest that called woman with
bright blue eyes
he took her to the other side of the
wall and declared himself as the night's
king their lawmen reign lasted for 13
years whereupon the free folk rallied
under the banner of a
king-beyond-the-wall a march against the
nat king seat against the Nightfort
which resulted at night's king defeat
with an aide of House Stark
earlier in gaming turns to learned that
the beleaguered White Walkers night King
is able to create that White Walkers but
it seems that he can only create one if
that human being is a pure-blooded
incest born as some kind of proof we
have a few scenes in which Crestor is
sacrificing his assess born babies
including a scene from the fourth season
in which Reyes places Craster's final
son on the ground in the Haunted Forest
or upon the White Walkers approached and
took the baby carried it towards a
shadow mountain in the lands of always
winter once the white Walker approached
an icy outer ring by large I see spikes
he plays the baby upon the altar upon
the leader of the night King approached
gently gathered the baby in his arms and
placed his index finger up on the baby's
cheek which caused the baby's eyes to
turn icy blue and it skin to grow pale
they seen from the fourth episode of
season 4 in my opinion conference my
statement that only incest born pure
blooded human beings can become a by
Walker
while every other human beings can only
become a white a reanimated corpse
raised from death by the white walkers
to act as their minions this means that
the night's king could turn then into
one of them since then is a pure-blooded
instead born daughter king garrison
Queen rhaella Targaryen the only way for
the living sight went along now it is to
either defeat them which would be
insanely hard or to make a pact the
Specht of Ice and Fire would include
Danny have you ever wondered why is the
night king even coming south why was he
preparing an army all those years with
which he started marching south at the
moment of Dana's arrival at Westeros I
was wondering about that ever since the
60s and ended and I came to a conclusion
that Danny's rival the Westeros
histories of the nine Kings preparations
the reason of his march south and his
reason of every single death that the
Seven Kingdoms is going to confront then
he could have owned the throne as soon
as she ride the Westeros if she wanted
to as John stated Danny did not take the
throne yet only because many in the
people would have died if she decided to
strong King's Landing she did not attack
in planning because she did not want to
cause death upon millions of innocent
people and she won't ever sit on the
Iron Throne because she will decide to
give her life so those people including
her
could live those battles between the
living side and White Walkers
accompanied with their white horde will
take a lot of casualties for both sides
but every casualty of the undead army
will be replaced by a casualty of the
linked side since all brave soldiers are
going to sacrifice their life on the
battlefield in order to stop the night
King and his army will be erased from
death and will increase the numbers of
the undead army upon a huge amount of
casualties and upon realizing that our
chance to survive the long night is
small the living side will decide to
stop fighting and we try to establish
peace we'll try to arrange a pact with
the leader of the white walkers now we
are coming to a pact that I mentioned
earlier a pact between the link side and
the night King an agreement which Daniel
accepts to end the long night a pact
imageshield became the night screen this
is an agreement which will save estrus
sacrifice which Danny as a true queen
will accept to save her people's lives
then his illusions are foreshadowing the
Danny could easily win the Iron Throne
and sit on it but it also foreshadows
that she will realize that she will not
be able to sit on the same since she
will have to give up on it for the
greater good she will accept the pact
with a knight King in order to end the
long night Danny will become the night's
queen whereupon she in a night King will
go beyond the wall and rule over it as a
form of peace agreement between the
living and the dead beside Danny's
agents as I've already said earlier in
this video Danny survival of Westeros
sedan at King's preparations that his
march to the south fits perfectly in
timeline I don't think it's coincidence
that all those years nothing was
preparing and gathering huge army with
which he started marching south at the
same time of Dana's arrival at Westeros
also the fact that the show included
multiple scenes that are proving that
Annette King can create that White
Walkers only that human being is a
pure-blooded instance born has to be for
sharing something huge to that the fact
that Danny's incest bone daughter of
King Aerys and Queen rhaella Targaryen
and this theory has a huge chance of
coming true
not only that this theory would be one
of the greatest surprises that
showrunners could pull off but it would
also fit perfectly with a bittersweet
ending that George our Martin announced
the enabling the steerer die and hence
of the night king as Danny it was
shortly after open arises the night
screen in the season 8 premiere same
upon revealing to Chang his show
parentage ask him if Danny would give up
the crown to saber people just as Jean
did and it's in my opinion huge gains
for what's to come
Danny would definitely do everything for
people and what the
conversation foreshadows is that Danny
will in fact do anything for people even
if it means giving her life for them I
still believe that this theory of mind
that includes Danny becoming tonight's
queen will come true and I believe this
conversation between Sam and John is for
sharing a huge sacrifice Danny will take
for her people then it will go beyond
the wall with the night king where they
will live for a thousand years however I
do not think this symbol has anything to
do with it it's not a Targaryen sigil
it's ancient sable of the children the
forest used in the rituals and the
children of the forest created White
Walkers for the night King the symbol
represents his birthplace in a number in
the center of the spiral just like the
human was when he became the night king
it's a message and it's basically him
saying he remembers what they did to him
as of the symbol referencing the
Targaryen special it's more likely that
the Targaryen sigil is referencing it
and not the other way around
after all the symbol does appear in
Dragonstone where the Targaryen have
been since the doom of Valyria the
symbol comes from the children of the
forest chronologically the first
appearance of the spiral comes from the
two where Draven shows bran the creation
of the White Walkers in the season six
episode the door just before the
children on the forests planchet
journalist dagger into a man's chest the
camera pans up and we see that he's tied
to a tree at the center of now familiar
spiral pattern from then on we see the
symbol pop up in large groups of eye
walkers show up especially when they
kill things the earliest example of the
mysterious visual popping up in a shows
actual run happens in the very first
episode when White Walkers kill a group
of eiling's and arrange their mutilated
bodies in a pattern the symbol also pops
up in season 3 episode 3 when John Rivas
is the fist of the first men and sees
the Nights Watch men who were killed
have disappeared and all that's left are
pieces of their horses in a spiral upon
seeing it Mance Rayder says always the
artists meaning they always leave the
symbols after they're done with killing
and resurrecting the symbols also peer
deep in the jungle escapes of
Dragonstone is season 7 episode 4 the
spoils of war according to John the
children of the forest scar these
markings in memory of the battle they
fought alongside the first man to defeat
the white walkers in one post episode
the interview Co showrunner David
Benioff explained that these patterns
were originally created by the children
of the forest and had a mystical
significance to them
since then they have been co-opted by
the walkers it's the Nikes message and
the symbol likely depicts his birthplace
and what the Nike wants to say with it
is that he remembers in conclusion the
night king is not a Targaryen and what
his message says is that he remembers
and is coming after all of them I do
however believe that there are many
hints and for sheriff's hidden in season
8 premiere the Danny will become the
night screen and she will live for a
thousand years beyond the wall just not
with whom she originally wanted but with
the night King everything seems to be
building up to that
and even same statement to John you gave
up the crown to saver people would Danny
do the same might be a huge hint for
what's to come please let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comment section down below
tomorrow I will probably make a video in
which I'll explain you Game of Thrones
intro and bring you a few things that
most of you missed in the season 8
premiere including the white Walker GPS
tracker Kuiper's revealed intention to
devastate King's Landing and a few other
things so stay tuned for that and either
tomorrow or the day after tomorrow I'll
be bringing you a video for episode 2 as
well and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace
[Music]